that this meeting is being broadcast
live will also be available after the
meeting via the council YouTube channel
a further reminder that if you're not
speaking remember to mute your
microphone and if you wish to speak
during the meeting please use the raise
hand or the chat function at any point
you are struggling with your internet
connection
turning your camera off may help and I
stress the word may we have one main
item tonight and that's items six and
that is the impact that's that's of
Corbin 19 on the council budget the
investing the investment and the
suffered economy we have executive
members here I think councillor Ross is
here and but on whether councillor
Wright is here and council officers in
attendance Graeme Bentley who was a
director of Finance and Richard Ralph
director of place they will give members
an overview and update of the budget
situation and there are a few questions
that have been submitted by members that
I'm hoping that the executive members
will address and then I will open the
discussion up for all members and any
questions not able to be answered
tonight we can ask for written responses
to be provided at a later date if
there's anything that is confidential
then obviously I'll have to move any
confidential items that members may
discuss into the closed section but I'm
not expecting that to happen so with
that kind of introduction I will move on
to the agenda and the first item on the
agenda is apologies
I don't have any apology then nothing
can have been received so hopefully
we're all here item two is the minutes
and just to let you know that the
minutes of the last meeting will be
tabled at the next meeting item 3 is
declarations of interest if any member
wishes to declare an interest please do
so now I don't hear anybody so I'll move
on to item 4 which we do in the urgent
business and none have been received by
myself item 5 questions from the public
again none have been received by myself
so we now move on to item 6 and the main
item and this is to receive an update of
the position in Trafford from the
executive member of Finance and the
executive member for Housing and
regeneration and to discuss the
borough's continued response to Co bid
19 and so we have council ruff that I
said earlier the exact member for
finance it's council right here in
attendance I don't think he is a day and
we also have Graeme Bentley the Director
of Finance and Richard Rowe the director
of play so can I hand over to councillor
Ross I'm cute yeah that's I appreciate
the invitation to this it's love to see
everyone this afternoon and I will give
a brief update on the the council
situation and I'm sure then Graeme would
step in and fill in any any gaps I may
may leave and then I'm very very happy
and I hope there's lots of questions for
me over the financial situation in the
borough so there's been some coverage of
local authority finances in
in recent in recent days it is true to
say that it's up and down the country
local councils have been met with a
perfect autumn welcome storm of
increased costs related to covert and
also a fall in income that we can expect
to receive from different sources
Trafford is is you know reflected by
this as this has been quite clear and at
present the current forecast that we
have is that we're looking at forty two
point 1 million as a combination of
expenditure and funding pressures and
that we we forecast this can be a bit of
a moving feast though it's you know this
is our our estimation at the moment it
could well change as the pandemic
situation continues the grant that we've
received from the government in
different tranches that covers about
eleven point two million so that that
partly feels the the financial gap that
we have for this year and then we've
located about four point five seven
million in reserves that we could also
apply to that to that grant that leaves
us with a financial gap for for this
year that's about twenty six point 1
million work is going on at the moment
to look at how we close that gap I
mentioned this at the executive meeting
last night there was a lot of coverage
of the potential for a section 1 1 4 to
be issued for this council and for other
councils across the the country that is
not in the executives gift to issue that
is in the that is something that our
corporate directors financial systems
would would would issue if she felt she
had to however as an executive that is
something that we are very keen to avoid
so we are looking at ways that we can
close the gap over the over the next few
weeks and months and we'll be coming
forward with our proposals in due course
and so that's basically a very
high-level summary of where we are I'd
say more than happy to answer questions
on the final Pacific Oceans but I know
that Graeme may want to come in
now with it with a bit more information
okay thank Thank You councillor roster
ray him there yep can everybody hear me
I've never have not you zoom before yes
I can any much I think just to put this
into some sort of perspective and we
were go back to February we set his
account to the balanced budget for 2021
just over a month after that bid we were
hit with the implications that
councillor Ross has just stated in terms
of corvid what we're finding is every
obviously every authority across the
country it's going to be affected by
this differently authorities for example
white Trafford if if you just think
about its budget as a whole is net
budget for 2020 was a hundred and
seventy five million and how we pay for
that is broadly got a figure of awfully
a hundred million from council tax
income and the rest is from retained
business rates and included within the
return rates is a an element of
government funding for those that's not
significance I think the point I'm
trying to make it the council are
reliant on a lot of external income now
the impact that corvids having is going
to be extremely broad its is obviously
impacting in the short term on
expenditure and our week and we've bee
act the pressures from corvid and it's
affecting income streams for example car
park income traded services income that
we receive from providing services to
schools but it's also affecting funding
so we are constantly updating estimates
of those we do submit to mhm CLG
communities of local government they
request every local authority to give an
update on a monthly basis of their
estimate of the impact of this across
those three areas expenditure income
funding they are also asking us to look
at our reserves because when they are
collecting all the numbers nationally
it's haven't got the national numbers I
thought my head but it can just imagine
if traffic's gross number there as
councillor Ross said was 42 million it
translates into a big number nationally
so what we expect from this is that we
do have a dialogue through the Society
of metropolitan treasurer's that Nicky
Bishop its president of at the moment so
she's a representative with all the for
example that the district councils have
their body so this representatives from
that and also the County Council there
are were dialogue with CLG in the
ballroom just trying to work through
what the solutions are to this at the
moment we don't know what we suspect
will happen is that we will get an
element of hold in an essay an element
with we've up-to-date the figure Council
the Ross gave was 11 points just over 11
million we've actually had grab to 12
and a half but we actually have to use
so because they started this corvid
started in March we used a big to
support to expenditure in 1920 now that
was included referencing the out to it
before so going into 2021 there's about
11 million left
so government will look at potential for
funding but we suspect that will be
limited and they may also look at other
things for example how we account for
things around council tax and business
rate but what we don't know as yet is
what that
package solution could be now what they
will use is something called
burden-sharing
they will certainly expect authorities
to help themselves to use their reserves
and obviously also make savings and
obviously with the executive and the
corporate leadership team this is what
we quite busy and involved with doing at
the moment just in terms of the numbers
what we are doing at the moment is
preparing our first in year monitor
report which will go to executive on the
I think is that I think it's a 20th of
July so what that will do is basically
what we're basically doing at the moment
is obviously updating the impacts of
Kovac but then also assessing the impact
on the rest of our budget and the edits
it feels like we would bring in both of
those aspects together to see what the
actual position looks like and that be
presented to executive later on in July
I think what a must just add to that is
that when we look at our overall
expenditure pressures the figured
counselor roskov of 42 million what we
are also getting and there's other
expenditure being incurred on some squat
McWhite specific entities that are being
funded separately and and just by way of
an example of a few of those we've got
for example tested trace and the
outbreak management plan so without
separate funding for that we have formed
around reopening our high street safely
and we've got some infection control
followed in which we receive but
obviously the requirement have persons
of our care providers so there is other
funding as well being received covers
quite specific aspects of expenditure
so I think that's that probably
summarises any other update I'd like to
thank thank you for that I think there
was a number of questions I think there
were three questions that was sent in
written questions sent in I don't know
whether you received those did you
receive those yes I've seen those are we
going to get an answer from I'll try
blowing through them in order so the
first one I've got council tax and
business rates yeah I think it was a you
know in the report its projected that
it's a five percent decreasing through
obviously the pandemic people not being
able to pay and and I think the question
is around after furlough starts coming
to an end that could actually go up and
I suppose it's how we're going to
continue to monitor that and how we're
going to factor that in just to respond
to that obviously we've reported we've
reporter three times now to CLG and
they're quite keen on understanding the
impact on our collection our council tax
receipts so we've got data for April and
May in terms of the income received when
we did the first return which was the
report that was summarized in April we
have we have taken an estimate of five
or seventh
what we've seen is in April our tax
receipts were probably around 6% down on
where we'd anticipated what the
information for May was quietly more
positive about a reduction
all that income it was about just over
5% down I think what we've seen you know
what we're monitoring is the take-up of
our council tax support scheme so we
have received and I emitted to say this
we have allowed some additional funding
off going around what they call hardship
funding and that is specifically around
if you've got an increased take up
against your council tax support scheme
and we have seen quite a significant
shake-up in the first two months but all
I can say at this stage is that
obviously we're looking at the data on a
more viable basis and just feeding that
into the projection okay in terms of the
other questions I think one was around
the reserves and I think in within the
report it was something like 36 million
pound in reserves and the question
really was how much of this is
ring-fenced
her or in that whatever language you
want to use great if I am if I go first
we have been looking at each of the
different reserves we have and that's
where we've come up with thee that the
4.7 million that we believe that we
could use to apply to the gap of in
funding that we have we have this year
there's other places where we put
additional into the reserve so for
example the the budgets moving and also
the investment management as well we've
been putting stuff aside in the
anticipation that we would need to draw
on it in future but yeah we've we've
kind of gone through each reserve
line-by-line and realistically we've
we've seen that we've got four point
seven million we could use to apply to
the the existing gap the other types of
reserved obviously they are included in
the budget monitoring reports now in an
in the aid of having greater
transparency they that's really stuff
that we've looked at and we can't have
new
to to address the current financial gap
that we have okay now that that's findin
the the third question and final one
that was written question is if a
council is unable to set a legal budget
what is the process for a section 1 1 4
being issued specifically what is the
trigger point that sets it in motion
well with that and I'm sure grandma will
come in to clarify any but with that
that that that gift as it were as it is
in nikki bishops position as our as our
corporate director finance and systems
if she felt that we could no longer
function financially as a as a council
then she would issue a notice to the
chief executive executive and leader of
the council I think it's for 28 days but
Graham will will go clarify to basically
turn things around and then and if that
were not the case that that is when we
would probably look at having in in
unusual times the leader and the
executive be removed and commissioners
come in however we're not in usual times
at the moment and very much the message
that's coming through from mhm CLG is
that the musk or Nikki and gray must
talk to mhm CLG before proceeding with
with the section 1 1 4 process so I
would say if any any council if we kind
of remove the covetous situation at the
moment any council in normal time if
they had a twenty five million pound in
year budget it would have been one one
Ford already however as we've
established this is to a greater or
lesser extent happening to councils
across the country mhm CLG are obviously
cognizant of that and that is why before
any of that process is started they want
us to keep talking and well you know we
would see what happens from there in
terms of our own preparation so as I
said to you before as an executive it's
not something that we want to
countenance in trafford which is why
we're we're looking at looking actions
that can be taken
in year to address the currents of the
current funding gap I don't know if
grain wants to add anything to that but
so that's kind of where we aren't moment
yes just period from issue in the report
to Council I think this their response
period of thing there but as cows
they're asked quite rightly says what
we've got here is is exceptional
circumstances then it's not something
order there or anything sets of one one
for would apply to in the sense that
section 1 1 4 is there as if the pool to
to in effect address inherent financial
management this occurred over a period
of time not necessarily an incidence
like corvid needless to say I think that
the legislation and the requirements
have not been changed it's only to the
extent that under the original section 1
1 4 requirements that is the decision of
the session 1 5 1 officer obviously
through following dialogue with the
chief executive what what CLG have has
have asked for is that they are
consulted at the early stages where
where session will gone for books a real
distinct prospect so they want
consulting on because what one of the
issues of it if you in a section one
role for under the under the old regime
was that once the report to come to
council then they ought to be an embargo
and ceasing of spending and now that's
not something that CLG warrant in the
current situation if they realize the in
fact that she suspended the in fact that
would have to be quite serious so that's
why they're keen to get that involvement
with us and that does that's a
distinction it would bottom boarded
because the one one for notice actually
follows them at unfortunate state and
thanks for that and
I know that there are others waiting to
come in bond teeth questions are
finished counselor on stayin counselor
will evens but before that I noticed
Jennifer wanted to I think respond to
this particular question as well Jane
yeah just really to to endorse what
counselor Ross and Graham has said that
basically every council is bound by a
duty to set a balanced budget the
section 1 1 4 sort of arises where it's
clear that the funding without resources
in those circumstances it's the chief
financial officer who is required to
issue the report is just a a personal
duty that sticks with the CFO it's not
something that council can decide to do
but but it is always being seen as a
measure of last resort it's a step that
you would only take once you know if
you've got to a position where the
finance officer and chief executive have
been unable to work together with the
members to agree about his budget so we
have a long way to go yeah you know this
is something which is an emergency that
as hitters very quickly and so we have a
lot of steps that need to go through and
that includes working with the mhdo G in
terms of the council's budgetary
position overall but obviously the steps
that we need to take to review our
budget to see obviously that we are able
to set to reset the budget into a
balanced position within this year and
and and there are a number of unknowns
in that because at this stage we're not
still not clear we may get additional
funding from the government and there
may be other things that come into play
in terms of we've made projections on
the basis of income which may change as
as lockdown eases so there are a lot of
things that are uncertain that would
mean that it would be incredibly
precipitous at this stage to be looking
to issue any kind of report
that says that at this point in time
that we've reached that point of last
resort in terms of the budget so it's
really just to endorse what what the
other two have said in this regard thank
you for that I think just to comment
myself it seems from what I'm seeing
across the country that practically
every council has been the same kind of
position and they will be having these
kinds of discussions themselves now just
move on to councilor Anstey who that's
got a question and then councillor
Williams chairman thank you very much
and then it's a few questions actually
but I'll try and try and keep them brief
there's so many questions that come from
what you've said Tom and the first one
is that the you know the council and its
reliance on external grants and
government funding as you've noted is
pretty limited and so therefore has a
stable relatively stable income base
poke through council tax and business
rates and so one of the questions has
already been answered which was going to
be around what do it where do we where
do we see council tax collection in
future so don't need to ask that but if
you then talk about business rates and
there's obviously the reset that's
coming and in 2021
on the impact of that on the council's
butcher and - well what the council is
thinking in relation to an economic
growth and planning policy and town
centers and to continue to keep sort of
the economy of traffic thriving because
that clearly will be essential and to
maintaining a strong business rate space
which is crucial to the authority
suggest some comments and on that would
be helpful I mean I agree the agree with
the comments on a 1:1 for notice and we
clearly do not want to do that and not
Hampton sure where it has been done and
it's very restrictive it removes all the
decision-making from from the authority
equally Northamptonshire as balanced its
budget for the last two years and and as
those traffic but it's and it has built
up some reserves to weather this crisis
so I'd be interesting interested in your
view if you could give us a fly
of some of the savings that you might be
considering to bring forward for example
is the fortnightly green bin collection
going to be made more permanent I'm not
suggesting you thought about that I'm
just it would be useful to get an idea
of the types of things you just starting
to think about and then lastly is I'm
sorry in relation to savings what plans
are going to be put in place to make
sure they don't slip and then lastly is
just some comments around and the cumin
policy in supply chains and so the
extent to which the council may want to
get some support to I suppose with Starr
and to go through and go through all of
our contracts and supply chains to make
sure that we're gaining the best value
from them that's it for now a thank you
well there's another questions there I
don't know who's going to answer them it
councillor Ross I will happily make a
start and I'm sure and grain will come
in if he feels it's necessary to do so
and just I know you said that we've had
her answer on council tax what an
interesting option we've got quite a
high number of self-employed people in
in the borough and and that is having an
impact on our current council tax base
and people are suddenly finding
themselves losing the rink and I'm
moving on to universe of credits where
they've not being part of the scheme so
that's one of the reasons why we've been
you know we've been hit quite early on
with the the council tax and the council
tax collection and in terms of the
economic growth and planning I
completely agree we are and I know if
James was on the call he'd be saying the
same we're obviously very pleased at the
moment that we took that decision as a
council to to take control of with in
partnership with Ron Wood with Stratford
mal and of the Stanford quarter in
auctioning because I do believe that
gives us in conjunction with Brentwood
and local community a proper steer on
what we want to see in the town centers
and I think one of the
early indications from covet is that
people will be more shopping more local
or using the town centers more
particularly people working from home so
you know your you'll have people that
much closer to the markets it's a in
ultra um sale
Stratford Ernst and then they would have
been if they were commuting to another
city but most of the city center or or
another area so I think there's real
opportunity there looking ahead as to
how we support those support those town
centres look at what we need to do to
adapt them so that so that they can
manage with the current kovat situation
and I'm looking at housing and and you
know bringing more people in to live
close to those those town centers but
yeah you you know it is important that
we and we do value our businesses and
we're obviously doing as much as
possible to support our businesses
through what has been a very difficult
time in terms of savings I can't confirm
anything as yet in terms of what we're
planning on running on them looking at
in terms of savings
I think we're considering everything at
twenty five million as I'm sure you'll
be where it is a huge amount of money
against what has been a significant
number of cuts in the in previous year's
budget
so all I can say there are no easy
solutions to this and we will come
forward once we have got a cogent set of
plans put together and largely that that
that does we are kind of awaiting any
further indication from MH CLG of any
further funding or say schemes such as
capitalization capitalizing the the the
deficit that we have before we kind of
put forward the you know that we are
looking over the next few weeks and
months to do that finally in terms of
procurement working very closely with
with staris it also you'll be aware that
they they do an amazing job of working
closely with our partners in Rochdale
team side and stop thought we will be
reviewing everything we can in order to
make
hey we get best value but also boost as
much as we can the locals spend because
again local spend is incredibly
important to us it in in traffic and it
does really help boost the local economy
and you know we need to do as much as
possible to support our local economy
during what has been a torrid time for
his book entrapped and also nationally
but you've got a follow up Sean okay
yeah yeah you've answered it was just a
myth you were if you weren't able to say
what was savings which I understand and
you know when when you were likely to
sort of make public some of your
thinking if it's the next few weeks or
months that's fine okay right so I think
councillor Williams that the next person
I think in the chat chat the Council of
Western as indicated he might have a
common in response yeah Andrew did you
want to come in yeah apologies I was
late onto the call I realized belatedly
that I didn't have the link my fault so
apologies for that it was just a just a
brief comment really I mean council the
Ross covered much of it the business
rate research going back to 2022 I think
has been announced recently so clearly
back in the short term is positive news
for us in terms of keeping the proceeds
of growth so that we'll have a material
impact on our financial planning in in
certainly the next financial year in
terms of a positive and just do very
much endorse councillor Ross's comments
around local spend obviously that's
traveled in Trafford over the last
couple of years and according to two
stars statistics that's so really
important that when we are reviewing
contracts which is probably something
that will need to happen the social
value inherent in those contracts is
weighted as well as the pure financial
offer and that's something that's very
much a priority for us and I think that
the point the round savings is really
well made I think it's it is mentioned
in the report that members of the
committee received in advance just
around the
fact that we do anticipate that some
savings will slip this year as officers
are not focused on business as usual
activity in particular just by way of
one example the modernization strategy
that we have been bringing forward is
something that necessarily has stalled
as a results of Kovach and indeed the
digital strategy which we expected to
yield savings in the medium term clearly
our IT team have been working to enable
things such as this to happen as an
urgent priority side so I think it's
likely that we will have a better idea
in a couple of months of exactly what
has slept and and to what extent both
but it would be remiss of us not to
acknowledge that fact
thanks cherry was just really that point
around the business raids yeah that's
great thanks I know Richard Roe wanted
to come in on one of those to respond to
one of those questions
Richard yep thanks Jer and just pick up
on the point and follow up on council
Russell's comment around the economic
growth and planning from a planning
perspective and the number of planning
applications that we are receiving at
the moment over the last couple of
months is actually being pretty
consistent with the numbers that we were
receiving a year ago so we might have
expected a dip but actually we are still
seeing planning applications coming
through at scale that's really positive
in terms of setting a future direction
of travel travel of the investment both
in terms of the largest-scale schemes
but also the smaller schemes and
actually it is the household extensions
conservatives that type of household the
plan and applications are really
important to the local economy because
actually a lot of those jobs get tend to
be done by local businesses rather than
Nationals so I think that's a really
that's really positive in terms of
thinking about where we might go town
centers remain absolutely critical to
our economy and councillor Russell's off
already highlighted what we've done in
terms from our previous investment but
we are going to work to bring forward
our proposals particularly in Stratford
on the the Stratford master plan that's
something that we think that's really
important to bring that forward as soon
as we can
members will be aware of the issues
around into the Trafford Centre went
into administration
as of Friday that's a significant
concern for us in terms of which were
all in the local economy the jobs there
and the business that really generates
we are in contact with the chopper ten
to and into around their proposals and
we'd be following up with the
administrators but it's positive to see
that it continued to tread over the
weekend and the indications are the
tougher center will remain open which is
very positive and more broadly in that
area Trafford Park as a whole is a
significant employer and a significant
driver of the local economy so we will
be following up work with the Trafford
Park business neighborhood network just
to understand where those businesses are
and any challenges that there and but
economic growth is and will be
absolutely central to our our recovery
plans and our recovery proposals and and
linking into a broader work around
schools schools and employment to ensure
that as the economy changes and I think
we will expect to see the economy change
in the forskohlii period that our
residents have the right skills and our
businesses have access to people who've
got the right skills thank you thank you
Richard and Kent can I bring in
councillor Williams now and then I think
council Coggins wanted to speak I just
wanted us can really feel a bit of
clarification about the executives
thinking around reserves that and also
about the advice that's been received
around utilising reserves to mitigate
the financial impact of kovat councillor
Ross well and also your chair yourself
chair will be away from the budget
scrutiny process the number of us have
expressed concerns about the relatively
low level of reserves that the local
authority holds on to and particularly
in relation to some of the neighboring
or authorities in Greater Manchester and
I just wanted to know whether there's
any
soon really that that could put us in a
comparatively weak position to try and
combat the financial impacts of covert
and whether or not there has been more
comprehensive advice from MH CLG about
the use of reserves and then outside of
that I was also just wondering on the
question of time scale moving forward I
think mr. Bentley
referred to the union monitoring report
in sent to executive on the 20th of July
is it
I was just wondering would that be a
point of which we have a much more
comprehensive understanding of the
financial impact and what will need to
be done because at the moment all we've
really heard is over the upcoming weeks
and months so I was just wondering you
know is there a concrete point at which
we know the local authority is going to
have to do something with thank you Joe
thank you for that and I think you're
absolutely right we have raised that at
the budget setting scrutiny that we took
place I think was a topic of
conversation and I think it was touched
on with the written questions in
relation to earmarked with those readers
Kemetic 36,000 pounds sounds a lot 36
million pounds down a lot and until you
actually break that up into absolute
commitments and what is actually usable
over to you that counts whereas thank
you very much for those questions yes
the the the level of our reserves it's
historically being low compared with
local authorities and it does mean that
we don't have the capacity of say over
other authorities to use our reserves to
help us with to the extent that so
telcos would be that the current funding
challenges we face as I said to you
previously we have gone
through each reserved line-by-line
looking for kipapa scope to to get the
muse and help with the current financial
situation and we've established we've
got about 4.7 million we can apply this
year but know it is a worry I mean and
it will be the case in the longer term
the piece over all parties may have more
reserves that will have more reserves
and us and more use them to sort this
it's current challenge out but once
reserves have gone they're gone so in
the longer term other authorities will
face the the immediate pressures that
the traffic does but this is a
historical situation all I can say is
that at the at the start of this this
this financial year we did look at
putting money into reserves where we
could do given the already tight
financial situation you know that we
operate in given yeah we put money into
is where we could do to try and help us
as we go along with this this now
increasingly difficult journey with God
so this this budget but yeah we've
looked at everything we can
I wish you know we historically had more
than we did but I think it's probably as
you know been for as long as traffic
existed I I think this has been the case
without our reserves I don't know if
Graeme wants to add anything to that
from his perspective yeah just just in
terms of the point around them guidance
from CLG particularly when we've been
fill in the monetary returns for corvid
to them they do ask the question around
what reserves can we peeps in and I
think I think I asking the question to
be honest there's an element of naivety
and misunderstanding from CLG as to what
our requirements are because I think as
part of the budget process at the
requirements statutory requirements of
the chief finance officer
the world war so the reserves the
council hold is a component to the
budget report and we've got to have a
robust budget and a minimum level of
reserves to cover them the wide variety
of risks that the council has oh I think
it's just one of those things that we
have reviewed them and obviously we do
not we'll have to use so to mitigate
some of the issues this year our ability
to use in this certainly constraint
that's what authorities a national
statistics come out in terms of the sips
of resilience index and them something
last week from the Institute of Fiscal
Studies where the basically benchmark
our reserves and what our risks are and
reserve levels are quite a high risk for
the council so we do realize we will
have to use them but we must exercise
extreme caution when doing that sorry
chai in terms of the second point that
Aiden raised in terms the monitoring
report I think we are using that as the
the point in time where we assess what
the what the likely gap is going to be
for the year and that will be used as a
basis going forward as to how we
addressed that that that that gap so
we've obviously was April made you know
a quarter of the way through the
financial year now so time is running
out to address the situation but the you
know the the publication of our first
monitoring report for the year will
provide the basis for the actions that
we we then take and the actions that
will bring forward to the council with
regards to how we feel the the financial
gap thank thank you
councillor Coggins thanks chair and some
comments on the reserves just 2m I mean
again belatedly and repeatedly welcome
the the administration's efforts to put
money into the reserves it was something
our very low level of
serves when I entered the council 2018
was something that's been a concern to
us and I suppose we've been an even
worse state had it had that not improved
and they've done some questions around
really the kind of new way of life that
people have at the moment and there are
as likely to be maintained as we come
out of this and in particular around
working from homes how that's going to
impact on the local economy and our town
centers and in turn then on our business
rates income and the council's of their
incomes so I suppose there's two sets of
questions there people are spending more
time in their town centers they're
working home there may be nip into their
local town center for lunch instead of
going to the city center and have less
commuting go and have more money spent
hopefully locally in Trafford which is
all good and to six questions one does
this impact other councils of state so
as a landowner for a lot of Trafford and
if our own staff are not coming into the
office is there any way that we can
generate income by say leasing would
obviously be preferable to selling or
for any other estate and and certainly
really about how we can support our tent
centers and local economy and really a
call I suppose for us to look at the
evidence-based and to make make
decisions based on that rather than
based on anecdotal evidence or you know
what was what was normal before now and
we know that an investment in active
transport has a huge positive impact on
the local economy and on our tenth
centuries and our local small businesses
we know it helps to reduce congestion
which is a huge drain it actually has
been shown to increase retail vitality
and actually reduce absenteeism so
there's really a lot of very strong
arguments for and focusing as much as we
can on getting people moving smoothly
and easily in an active way and just as
was called for that to be to be
considered as part of our that's part of
our financial strategy yeah thank you
very much but I mean there that really
really important points and the kind of
touch on stuff that I responded to
earlier and yeah I'm an optimist in
terms of the
the positive changes that could come out
of what has been a horrendous situation
for us in the country over the past few
months I do think it has it will change
behaviors I think working from home has
become normalized for many people now
and it is the it is the case within in
Trafford that a number of our our
officers are quite happy and comfortable
with working from home and I think where
it is possible for them to do so and
doesn't turn effect or impact the year
that the running of the organization
they should be allowed to continue that
and that does move on to our estate as
as you rightly point out that is an
option that's on the table we will look
at where we we no longer have the need
for that kind of death space and look at
what we do with that as a term in terms
of looking at how we how we save how we
save money how we generate an income
anything that can help with our current
financial situation I think active
travel is is and remains important to us
as a borough I think the stuff that
we've done around Stratford in
particular has been has been successful
and I know with my my ward councillor
hats on at the moment that is something
that we definitely would want to
incorporate into a long term vision for
for Stratford town centre and it is
important but for all the reasons you
say about active travel IIE
I completely agree and I think as a
council and and we do need to and I know
we will do harness that that move
towards shopping local and the fact that
there will be a number of people now
that as I said earlier will not be going
into city centres or other places to
work they will be in their local
communities and so we need to make that
real push to support our businesses and
get people supporting our local town
centres whether that be part of cinsay
or Stratford erm stand altering and Hale
and you know although those areas
there's a real potential for us locally
with the town since we have to get them
supported by our local populations and
you know whether that be during the day
going for a sandwich or in the evenings
you know going for a drink or whatever
people choose to do with
with their social time so there's real
opportunities there and there's real
opportunities for our local economy to
benefit from what has been a harem just
you know horrendous time for many
families and people across Boren and it
and it will remain that way but yeah I
think that there's a lot we can do to to
encourage working from home and also
encourage people to support the local
local economists and okay thank you for
that John
I think also can I just say in terms of
new ways of working members should be
included in that because I think
obviously we have been working
differently when the meeting differently
we've probably been traveling
differently and I think you know we
should be involved to actually move
forward in the new ways of working and I
hope that no encouraging remarks that
you've made that members can actually
help in relation to that development of
the new ways of work there are two
members raise their hands I believe but
I've not got a clue who they are so
those are because I hey it's not coming
up on my bar at all and I don't know why
I don't know whether Alex can tell me
who those members are okay Kath counts
where and D is one so can you come in
I'm happy to is three follow-up
questions we focus haven't spoken sure
I'm happy for that we've died well I'll
leave you for a little while
can't counselor new new grush thank you
yeah I just have a couple of questions
the effect it had on the investment fund
overall value and income and the support
we've had for the airport I'm happy that
has to be dealt with it under exclusion
but that's for you to guide me on
okay we'll see how we go I'm sure Jane
will step in in fact if I urge towards
then closing us down in terms of the in
investment fund as it stands the the the
the main things that we're mindful of
our the retail aggression so the
Stanford water and the unstructured
mouth
however they were never invest we never
we never acquired those with the vision
of them giving us a financial return
they were for a regeneration purposes
and I still think now more than ever
they were important for us to to go into
a partnership with Brunt would over
because it gives us a chance to shape
the futures of the two town centers
whether it's building on the success
that oxygens heart or really supporting
and nurturing a new town center for the
Stratford area in terms of the the other
things at the moment there that there
isn't any cause for concern at the
moment but obviously every investment
decision that we've taken we've always
had due diligence with and we have put
some mix extra money into our our
particular reserve because we are
mindful of the fact that you know that
these are things where the income could
could could decrease well as it stands
at the moment the the information they
have is that that really is if the
retail segment book - that that isn't a
surprise to us and actually that's not
why we acquired the the Stanford quarter
in terms of the airport's obviously the
the the the the loss of the dividend is
a is a huge impact for us and it would
be the same over the next few years the
airport remains a key part of our local
economy it's a key employer and and I do
believe it is it is important that we do
all we can to to to make sure people
don't lose their jobs in in in the in
the airport all that setting and we just
have to see as things relax how best the
airport recovers it's gonna I think it
you know it looks like it's going to be
slow with the social distance
processes and measures but it's still
early days
well yeah we recognize it as a key
economic asset for that for the area and
also a key employer of people that live
in our borough I'm trying and I'm kind
of trying to balance the the wording
that I have there but fine yeah yeah
we okay with that right it's running and
anybody else before I bring council on
today back in well right sure
thanks so much on them and thanks for
these answers so the the three
follow-ups I wanted to have them to
counsel of us was my extent and what was
your assessment the earliest phase of
the additional spend or lost income that
is directly covered one-off related for
this year versus a recurring theme in
the budgets going forward so I would
assume that the the increase for example
in social care charges is going to be an
ongoing cost that we have to recover
what presumably parking income and the
loss of that this year will recover so
just where on the on a scale of where do
you where do where do you assess that to
be that would be useful to know because
I think it determines obviously the
response that you need to give and then
and then two other questions to Richard
really I suppose and one is so welcome
the comments really I suppose around
town sentences and so on and but it's
what thought is going into making the
council easy to do business with so
there will be some subjective so the
planning policy for example are we going
to speed up at the local plan process
are we going to give some certainty to
where development can take place and the
type of development that can take place
developers are coming to the council to
say you know a scheme won't be viable
and you know there's always trade-offs
isn't there in planning policy and
giving permission
what's the council's view on planning
policy in future and how easy it will be
to do business with and then sort of
link to that and it's linked to its
Geraldine's point if the council is not
going back to work and will be in
I'm working from home more frequently so
will businesses so all the businesses so
it became two sort of leasing out space
in Council buildings and that that
perhaps might not be able to follow
because everybody else is doing the same
thing which inevitably leads to a review
of the entire land holding of the
authority and then disposal of it and
you know if you are allowed to
capitalize and revenue expenditure as a
way of being able to and overcome some
of these challenges and is there a view
at the moment on no some pretty tough
decisions that the council might need to
take on what it disposes off and sort of
link to the second question or it can be
used for thank you we're estimating that
the recurring pressure will be about 17
million for next year however it's in
all honesty it's difficult to see what
the longer-term cost would be so for
example one example that you gave about
Part C parking fees it depends what
people will weather habits change and
people do come back to town centers and
park or whether they use of the means or
yeah and all go wait it's just really
difficult to to estimate what we think
it's about seventeen point three million
that would be the recurrent issue which
obviously in terms of next year's budget
gap we were already for forecasting a
fifteen million budget gap for next year
so our potential gap looking ahead to
twenty one twenty two is currently just
shy of thirty three million so you know
regardless we've got a very difficult
few years to navigate to the council but
yeah it is about seventeen million in
terms of recurrence and kovat costs
looking at the next year okay just
answer the question okay answer the
first one I mean as I say around
planning policy and lung disposal and
capital receipts would be
thank you very much yeah I don't know if
Richards okay I'm still here so thanks
for the questions
Sean and I mean I would hope at least we
set ourselves up as being easy to do
business with in any way that's from a
planning perspective that's something
that we definitely want to do and as you
will know as ever in planning there's
been easy to do business with from the
developer perspective but also balancing
that against the needs of and desires of
local communities and ensure that we do
things that have the support from local
communities and so that means it isn't
just as easy as as opening the doors to
developers because we need to see both
sides of the debate and from the local
plan we are absolutely continuing to
build West work on the local plan and we
are reliant on the work on the GMs F the
Greater Manchester spatial framework
because of the planning policy structure
as we currently set still relies on the
spatial framework coming forward because
that provides the overarching planning
strategy within which the local plan
sits and so that's something that we're
continuing to work on on an individual
opponent application the view then we
will take a view on viability the
administration's priority is around
delivering affordable housing that's
something the remains very important to
the to the administration but there is a
recognition that there is a balance and
there's a viability debate at least we
don't we will always look at viability
on any case and and we're also keeping
an eye on some of the discussions coming
out from central government around
extending permitted development rights
then we need to have an understanding of
what that might mean in terms of council
buildings and office estate I think
there's a there's an interest in debate
taking place on for property owners
around how office estate might get used
and there is something about balance
that whilst there is an expectation that
and there will doubt it'll be more
working from home from
future I think most of the people that I
talk to there's also actually and ask
for businesses who want more space for
the staff who do coming to the office to
work in a different way and so I share
some of councillor Ross's optimism
because I'm an optimist as well that
there's a potential for some of that to
start to balance out so you might have
more people in the office but actually
they're those people are going to be
working in a more socially distance way
and they're gonna use that office in a
different way maybe than they did before
us it doesn't necessarily reduce the
space across the sector I'm not talking
about individual furrows for the council
as has been discussed then undoubtedly
reducing our offices there is something
that we are considering that we're
thinking about what we do with that is
something that will then need to be
determined in this part of the it's part
of that thinking process but where there
are opportunities for us to take to
continue with the strategy and develop
faster the current strategy around
redevelopment of our assets that's
something that we are very keen to do so
so schemes of the like of Brown Street
entail where we we generally we
developed in one of our assets for
housing development whilst maintaining
Kappa the scheme that went to executive
on Tuesday night which I know you're
very familiar with Shawn and the
redevelopment of the Jubilee Center in
broader where again we're trying to
regenerate that asset we developed that
asset in a way that maintains the
community base but also drives a return
for us trying to take that way of
working and that way of thinking to the
to the rest of our estate and thinking
about how we use that and there may be
options for conversion of office space
into residential where the footprint and
the floor play of that estate makes
sense so I think everything's on on the
table and it's a it's a significant
piece of work that's that's required
around that and and all doubt that there
are always tough decisions to be made
when you ask that start looking at
reusing assets in a different way that's
why we needed to have that debate we
need to have a little bit with the local
community
unknown boasts about how we go forward
with us quickly and to totally get all
of that and I think it's welcome things
like you know the Jubilee Center and so
on I think it's done right is really
really really keen to see it's about
expression at scale really if the gap is
13 odd million and and Commission comes
from government to capitalize that
whereas the council's going to get its
capital form as it from borrowing or is
it from large asset disposals which
clearly are or not which is a
significantly larger than brown story
and the Jubilee Center and and and and
that tension that exists which I'm very
familiar with between you know the
council's needs is an organization and
perhaps the conflict that sometimes
arises with communities is what position
is the administration going to take on
that and there's no right answer there's
no right or wrong answer I'm just
intrigued as to what your thinking is on
that on that because it's it's
significant scale isn't it
and I'll be quiet actually I thank you
and I think the question is that there's
a large hypothetical in that in that
question Sean so it does depend on will
the government give us the ability to
capitalize and any of our revenue
pressure I don't think we have the
answer to that at the moment and there
is no if that option is there it is
something that we would have to consider
but I don't think that necessarily means
that we're able at this point to start
thinking about how we address the second
part of your question in terms of how
that capitalization is done historically
and over recent years as you know it in
general our capital program is driven by
a combination of borrowing but
predominately we look to use capital
that we generate from either land sales
are from development and I would expect
that to continue but I don't think we
can get into the details of the scale of
capitalization then that might be
required and now that might be funded I
think a little bit it's too far down the
line in terms of the hypotheticals that
go with that thank you I can see that
the lead on drew Weston wants to come in
just on this point
yeah thanks Jerry's probably to give us
by the and
more political sphere on the answer than
Richards obviously able to obviously its
case-by-case Sean in terms of the assets
in question but certainly in terms of
the way that I have asked officers to
look at drawing or proposals is that we
would put people before assets wherever
possible so I don't want to be in a
position where we're making hundreds if
not thousands of our workforce redundant
and clearly with a with a budget
challenge that we're facing over the
next couple of years you know we do need
to consider all options before we get to
that so whilst it would be on a
case-by-case basis and it would depend
on the assets that we were were talking
about it's certainly the case as you say
which changes to working patterns that
it may be that some of our estate is no
longer required for the purposes that it
has been required before it's too early
to say definitively but certainly along
with really focusing our efforts on
delivering an inclusive economy and not
looking if at all possible to undermine
investment and invest to save
initiatives one of the other key
aspirations that I have is that we that
we do prioritize our people before our
assets as a council and that's just to
ensure that we can continue delivering
key services but clearly that is a very
general answer because it depends on the
specifics of what we're dealing with and
also where we get to in terms of the
financial options available to was
around capitalization or indeed any
other support that might be forthcoming
thanks Chad okay thank you any other
questions that anybody got no and I have
just God's house abode it's a comment on
a question clearly you know we dependent
on government to give us steers in terms
of you know how we have to actually
handle all of this the financial and you
know fallout from the
demek and I know that the Prime Minister
said to local authorities we need to
fund what he does salutely necessary in
terms of the pandemic and I think that's
what most councils have actually done I
look at the report and I do see that
there was two tranches I think of
something like 1.4 million the pound and
we could receive one of them and we
haven't received the other that yet I'd
have died understand from the record
that might have changed and I suppose
what I'm thinking is in terms of our
lobbying of government because they
clearly recognize there are you know
significant issues financial issues in
all councils and I was wondering how the
best way to lobby in terms of the
council handle what is the thinking in
relation to whether we will get further
funding okay thank you for that I think
from from from my own spoke one of the
issues we've had is that the government
hasn't acknowledged the income loss part
of the the funding situation that we
find ourselves in so they've provided
money for the increased costs but they
haven't thought about the various losses
of income that are set out in the the
report that was shared with the scrutiny
members and that is where we're getting
at you know significant part of our you
know funding gap from from an early
stage in terms of lobbying and raising
raising concerns and I know that Andrew
is the leader wrote asking for more
resource and there's a lot of work going
on at an LGA level cross party because
political you know the council's of
political colors that are all facing the
same same issue so there's a lot of
cross-party work happening at the LGA to
try and push for for more funding it's
just it's it's it's it's it's difficult
and I don't think people I don't think I
don't think people fully acknowledge the
amount of services that councils do
provide and the risk that we have of
those suddenly disappearing because of
the council's not being able to afford
to do them anymore and I hope there's a
realization and there's real national
narrative builds before it's too late so
people recognize that that all the good
work that the council's do whether it be
the street cleaning the collection of
bins the libraries you know the list is
endless of stuff that there's the real
bread-and-butter stuff of politics that
is actually delivered by by local
councils and and if local councils are
in a position to do that then local
communities and local societies are
really going to suffer quite badly and
they think there seems to be a bit more
movement now in terms of the national
coverage of the plight of councils and I
hope that nationally that that that that
does continue because it is society's
lost if councils aren't able to to
function and carry on all the good work
that they have been doing for many years
and actually we are the most efficient
and probably the most popular part of
the government you know I think I think
local politicians and I'm not just you
know these are these are these are
survey results therefore you know local
politicians are trusted more than
national politicians councils are very
efficient with regards to the funding
they have I've been and all councils
have gone through varying degrees of
austerity over the past ten years and
had largely come out with it obviously
with massive changes but functioning and
Babel being able to offer things in in
in you know challenging circumstances so
I do hope more people see and value what
we what we have to offer at a local
level before it is too late
before we do have to start making those
difficult decisions to balance our
budgets and yeah cross-party work goes
on at the LGA I know that politically
you know different different parts of
different approaches to it but certainly
it's in everyone's interest to fund
local councils because they are very
important part of the local community
and and yeah provided a number of
crucial local services thank you for
that and another question really is
about statutory services clearly you
know a statutory service we have to
carry out a statutory work that we do do
and you know we want to do that well
what is the thinking in terms of what
the impact of this might have on
statutory services and what can be what
savings can be made for those services
that are not stunted tree you know what
would happen as that work being done in
terms of looking good issues that work
is ongoing and hopefully you know we'll
be in a position soon to come forward
with with with the proposals that that
we have to address the the funding gap
I'm obviously very happy to keep coming
back to this committee of people wish me
to to explain that at times where we
have a bit more information to discuss
us that's something I'm very happy to do
but what I would say before before
anything does come forward but there are
no easy decisions to take here local
authorities have ever met immense
pressure over the past decade and yeah
it's going to be very difficult so I
hope in the meantime that we get some
support greater support from from
central government to make sure that we
manage to keep holders as many services
as possible but as an
we have proposals that we are we are in
a position to to share with you I'm more
than happy to come back share and I'll
be questioned by the committee again
thank you very much
councillor Lam you raised your hand I
did indeed chair thank you very much
indeed and it's just really on the last
points that councillor Ross has been
making and it sounds to me as though the
July report to go to the executive which
updates on the overall budget gap is
going to be important so hopefully that
will come to to us as well I just
wondered though whether I was looking at
the term that was used when Graham
Bentley was talking before he talks
about burden-sharing which of course is
how that gap gets closed between local
resources and central government
resources and I think that I was going
to us a question earlier about what our
thoughts were about how that burden may
fall if you'll height between local and
central resources but I think Graham
actually indicated that there was
probably so many unknowns at the moment
it could probably be difficult to say
however if it is a view on that now that
would be useful but at the same time
that we see that July update it would be
very useful to to have a view on how we
see that sort of burden falling which
I'm sure is germane really to the whole
issue of the impact that it then has on
existing Trafford services okay thank
you Jeff thank you if that's okay with
you in terms of the burden sharing it I
would hope and you'd expect me to say
this anyway I would hope that the
government does support councils and
actually addresses that the enya gap
completely the difference that we've had
compared with
with national government is obviously we
can't at the moment we can't borrow to
fund a deficit for a number of reasons
but we've also got a duty to deliver a
combination of statutory and very
valuable services to the local community
so I do think it's a within the
government's interests to take the
burden from us given the expectation
that government has the roads to start
looking at managing and responding to
local outbreaks of kovat and and another
such thing so and my hope now is that
the government value and recognize what
local authorities across the country are
doing and actually support us through
this difficult time
because they've got the the mechanisms
in place to take this burden from us if
we were to take part of this burden or
all of the burdens it looks like at the
moment terms of the 26 million that's
obviously going to have a very grave
impact on what we can deliver and
that'll be the same across across over
authorities so so weary we're really
looking at at this point in time too for
the government to take the burden for us
so that we can we can continue
functioning and delivering services for
our local community but once the you
know one one what's the first report of
this year's budget monitoring comes out
very happy to come back then and talk
further because we'll be in a clearer
position then as well as to what the
government's stance will be thank you
no that's useful thank you very much Tom
but I mean the reality as we probably
know is that you know sounds like the
government won't take a hundred percent
of the burden and I suppose the question
then is you know what wallet what would
be the the the sort of split if you like
which the council would be able to sort
of live with and I've no doubt that
would be some thoughts about that but
that's kind of work that's going on you
know what's the you know what's the
what's the minimum that we would receive
from central government that would allow
us to
to continue in business as in well yeah
I mean that that is work that's going on
but at the moment what we're preparing
for is addressing the the gap as we see
it so the the 26 million with the hope
and the you know the view that the
government should and could step up and
support us further well as it stands at
the moment the the the gap that we are
forecasting is twenty six million and
that is what we're working on at the
moment to look at in you in you
decisions we can take to to meet that
gap but they won't be easy decisions
okay are there any other questions no I
just have a final question then
obviously when we set up this pandemic
scrutiny committee you know part of the
terms of reference for the community was
working with the executive and I just
wondered if there's anything that you
think a piece of work promised would
help in you know in terms of the budget
processes I'm not saying you you have to
respond to that now but I think the
offer that will be there from for
members to to health and support in
terms of this very difficult issue that
we all fade and we do all face in
whichever party we belong to we we face
you know a very difficult situation and
so maybe it's one that you want to
ponder on the leader of the well how
much she would want you know support the
work that you're trying to do in
difficult tone
thank you I know I completely agree and
it's good to have these sessions for
executive members and members of the
committee committee to to to discuss
these issues what I would say is that I
know that there is a vast wealth of
experience of members on this committee
and they all bring things from both
their political experience and also from
that their experience in business or the
public etc in their own roles outside of
the council so there is a vast wealth of
experience in this committee and it is
important that you play parts well as we
as we as we move ahead during you in
these even these very challenging time
so if there is specific stuff I will let
you know but certainly just focusing in
on on areas that you have concerns are
so for example the the ongoing work the
previous leaks cooter you've been doing
around around reserves and looking to
looking at lack of those reserves and
and how they function that that was
actually quite helpful you may want to
look at other aspects of the budget and
just dig a little bit deeper
using Europe you collective expertise to
help inform us as an executive thank you
that's great and right did no other
other questions and I can just ask I
will just say thank you to councillor
Ross the leader and Richard role and
going Bentley and doing the Ferb I think
you you you can leave the meeting now
but thank you so much for answering
those questions in depth just for
members of the pandemic committee can
you just stay for five minutes so we can
just have a chat amongst ourselves
in terms of how taking thanks everyone
thank
by right does anybody have any comments
in terms of how we might move forward I
think that Alex and John Addison would
have captured a lot of the stuff that
you know we've gleaned out of today's
meeting and yeah yeah so yeah no joke
John Addison did me want to come in no
agenda oh yes sorry about that
yeah but but just to finish this besides
I think what we'll try and do is collect
all the information and I think we will
have a panel meeting you know the the
agenda setting meeting I don't know when
that is it tomorrow so we can bring try
and bring it all together and then sort
of send and a report out to you know the
rest of the members is that okay and if
anybody wants to feed anything into
ourselves in the meantime overnight or
tomorrow morning do so and obviously
we'll keep everybody informed no John
lamb you wanted just to make a comment
no thanks David in its I'm just
following on from your comments really I
mean I think that
you know we clearly will have an
interest in how the extraordinary budget
gap guess get reduced and we may be able
to individually play our sort of roles
in you know
lobbying was mentioned and you know
individual members no doubt but I'm not
sure that it would be a good idea to
concentrate too much of our time on you
know what arguably might be the sort of
technical aspects of the budget in
closing that sort of gap gap important
and crucial though it is and I just
wondered whether as a scrutiny committee
we we might sort of be better to focus
on you know how do we ensure that
truffled is open for business as it were
you know what are some of the quite
different things doing the whole you
know the only debate the planning issue
was raised and as Sean talked about you
know how we sort of deal with the states
and you know capital all that sort of
thing and I'm just wondering whether you
know that more imaginative creative sort
of side of stuff the way we think we may
do things differently in terms of the
way people are working differently or
shopping differently on whatever it is
I'm just wondering whether we could add
if we want to add some value we give
some thought to those kinds of areas
otherwise we'll be you know in terms of
the budget we'd just be shadowing you
know the discussions that are going on
between the executive and governments
and all the rest of it which is which is
crucial but for us it's more interesting
I think yeah I think we should do all of
that you know I think it's really
important that we
you know we we try to work together in
terms of you know making recommendations
and so on about how we might move
forward in terms of the budget it is a
move moving feast as we know on a daily
basis basically and so I think if we try
and roll some of that up tomorrow in the
panel rather than do it here and I think
if anybody's got any further ideas they
can feed in you know whenever they wish
to feed in I think I think that's the
thing is that okay and David can I can I
just yeah well I mean first of all
thanks today with me and those questions
and then secondly and I mean what I took
from it was one it was very helpful but
two is very uncertain and I think
there's probably a role from
the scrutiny to try and get that
uncertainty to certainty because at some
point the executive is going to have to
make and recommend decisions to counsel
and it's and it's it's those decisions
and that I think are of interest and to
us and it would be you know so really
you know sort of gleaning from the
executive law you know Wendy when do you
think you're gonna have when you when
are you going to have at least if not
all of the informations sufficient
information to be able to start saying
these are the things that we're thinking
and these are the decisions that we're
proposing so that we can have a pre
sweet almost in the formative stages of
those decisions being made and we could
that we could have an input and I think
that would be really valuable for us to
be yeah I'm totally agree with that I
think that's what I would like to do so
we need obviously to try to bring it all
together and first and foremost because
there was a lot of information to be
chain on board and I think if we could
crystallize that into a wolf program for
ourselves then you know that that would
be useful that we can recommend them -
to - to the executive
and so we will do some of that tomorrow
I think but you know as I take on board
completely what you're saying right
so with that should we move on I don't
think we've got much more left in terms
of the agenda item 7 is to work program
and I think basically if you've got any
comments on that work program then or
changes to it and then then say so now
you've challenged are we happy with that
it is for noting anyway so okay yeah
right item 9 now with it no item 8 and a
few future meetings yeah this is the
report for noting and for members to
provide feedback or raise amendments to
it yeah okay right that concludes a
meeting because exclusion resolution do
we think we're not needed to use and so
is that okay can I thank you all for the
being up the meeting and the questions
raised thank you all very much and I
would say have a safe journey home but
you're already home so so have a nice
evening okay